presenter and queen of the jungle vicky
patterson who's
in the last half hour of her sleepless
night um good morning to you vicky i bet
the morning hasn't come around soon
enough for you
and have you managed through the night
oh hi
pal you look so fresh i'm so jealous
uh i i'm on i'm really it's the last
stretch isn't it and i'm sorry if i'm a
little bit tongue-tied
um i am feeling super tired now
looking a little bit like a little mole
as well
um not me finest and glamorous hour
but it's all for a very good cause isn't
it
yes it is indeed tell us how you managed
to stay awake
through the night i mean you were doing
various uh activities weren't you
yeah you know what i i couldn't have
done it like we had a last-minute
substitution
uh my mom came off the bench she wasn't
even signed up to do the event i was
meant to be doing it with my boyfriend
but um my mom has stayed up with us um
and
she's been doing a jigsaw for most of
the night she's having a great time
she's been an excellent moral support
watched some films did a little work out
with mr motavira
i've had my lovely little doggy keeping
me company
we've done some self-care up all night
as well oh
this one absolutely not total fraud he's
been catching cat naps the whole time
but
he's so fluffy and cute i let him off
yes i do
i love it the dog catching up cat naps
and so tell us why you've done this why
you put yourself through this
um a couple years ago actually it was
made me mom um became aware of the work
that center point do
we did a sleepout event for them um
which was their event
um before the pandemic obviously where
people got together and experienced a
glimmer
of what it must be like um to be young
and homeless
um but given the current climate we you
can't do that we can't have loads of
people sleeping on the streets for this
so
and this event in particular was was the
new one um
and after speaking to the center point i
realized
the year that we've had has been
horrible for everybody we've all had our
hardships and our struggles
but nobody has suffered more than young
people um if you look at the industries
that have been affected
most by the corporate 19 virus and the
pandemic it's
retail it's hospitality and who works in
those young people
so more so than ever now you've got
young people who can't pay their rent
who are facing homelessness
and i just felt like this pandemic had
exacerbated an already really tenuous
situation
and i knew that center point needed any
help and any sort of um
yeah the figures are quite shocking
aren't they uh center point saying 120
000 young people
face homelessness between 2019 and 2020
uh and that's increased by more than 10
000. so as you say
the situation exacerbated by the
pandemic
absolutely um i know i know we've all
had hard years and things like that but
there's now more than ever center point
need will help
um they have a huge goal to end youth
homelessness
um and i think if anybody can can do a
bit whether it's
donating sponsoring and signing up to
sponsor like a room
you can do that i just think if it's
within your realm of capabilities we
should give it a go
bit of kindness goes a long way than
earth no absolutely and three years ago
as you were saying that you slept
outside with a hundred volunteers in
in sunderland i think on that occasion
uh the charity raised what 300
000 pounds how much are you hoping to
raise this time round
oh god i'd love to smash that like i
think
it's a big ask because i know
everybody's had
a very difficult year but i think
what this year has shown where is that
we need to show everybody a bit more
kindness
we need to be supporting each other um
and just yeah being nice to our fellow
man so i think we've got this in the bag
i think we're gonna smash it
do we know specifically what the money
will be spent on
so center point help with a number of
things including
housing education vocational skills
health care
mental health physical health and it
goes across the board i've met a number
of
brilliant people who first hand have
been helped by centerpoint
to turn their lives around to realize
that being homeless
being homeless experiencing homelessness
it doesn't have to be
who you are doesn't have to define you
it isn't your story it can just be a
chapter
and there is something bright and
amazing for you after that so
um i know that whatever they do with
their money it's going to be changing
the lives of young people and it's going
to be incredible
yeah very positive indeed vicky thank
you so much for
speaking to us you've got about 20
minutes left hold in there
you can do it thank you that's good to
know you believe in us
thanks for speaking to us stay awake bye